so anything you want in five steps the  closer framework c clarify why the  person is there why do they even reach  out to you l label them with a problem  that you plan to solve oh overview their  past experiences or past pains that  they've gone through trying to solve  this exact same problem s sell them  vacation so you want to sell them what  they're going to experience what it's  going to be like when they experience  the result of what you're going to get  them not the way that you're going to  get them there e explaining where their  concerns so if they're worried or  they're hesitating or they're not sure  explain where they're concerned so you  can move them towards the finish line  and finally r is you want to reinforce  the decision that they just made so that  they feel good about it and then you  start the relationship off on the right  foot that's the closer framework